immer mehr menschen fliegen und während
die billig airlines mit 99 90 locken
schieben fluglotsen hochbezahlte
sonderschichten einfach um verspätungen
zu verhindern
flieger heben ohne gepäck abstatten
verspätet oder fallen sogar aus kurz
gesagt der flugverkehr ist am limit
insgesamt glaube ich sind ja alle schuld
weil wir natürlich gerne fliegen wollen
und zwar nicht teuer sondern wirklich
billig es ist schlicht zu viel die
branche wächst und wächst und die
systeme und die infrastruktur kommt
nicht hinterher
und auch fürs klima sollten wir alle
weniger viel so blöd es auch klingt am
himmel ist auch nicht unendlich viel
platz und so wie es aktuell läuft so
kann es nicht weitergehen
darum geht's in dieser folge summen
immer mehr menschen fliegen egal ob
beruflich oder in den hole auf 2018 sind
in deutschland 122 46 millionen menschen
in den flieger gestiegen so viele wie
noch nie und das hat auswirkungen die
ich jeder von uns kennt
langes warten an den
sicherheitskontrollen verspätung
flugausfälle im ersten halbjahr 2009 10
sind über 12.000 flüge von und nach
deutschland ausgefallen das sind etwa 66
flüge pro tag wenn man sich zum beispiel
berlin tegel anschaut wird schnell klar
dass es so nicht weitergehen kann
begehbar für 66 millionen passagiere
gebaut hier sind im moment bei 22 das
geht richtung vierfacher belastung da
kann man natürlich noch eine blech halle
bauen da kann man noch ein kleines
gartenhäuschen run bauen oder einen
wohnwagen wo man abfertigt wo man leute
irgendwie weiter führt tegel ist
ausgelutscht bis zum geht nicht mehr
viel zu viele passagiere für den
flughafen das berlin seit sieben jahren
auf den b erwartet ist ein anderes thema
und ob der für die menge an
flugreisenden ausreichen wird ist schon
jetzt strittig wichtiger ist was das
zeigt wir fliegen immer mehr aber die
infrastruktur dafür fehlt der ärger
beginnt bei den sicherheitskontrollen
und geht bei der gepäckabfertigung
direkt weiter beides ist bei verzögerung
nicht nur für passagiere nervig sondern
für die sicherheit verdammt wichtig und
an beiden stellen hakt es für die
sicherheitskontrollen ist die
bundespolizei zuständig die wiederum
andere firmen damit beauftragt dabei
entstehen teilweise absurde kombination
und ein wirrwarr aus sub sub sub
unternehmen die sicherheitskontrollen
sind häufig natürlich nicht der
performance wie man so schön sagt weil
einfach die sicherheitsfirmen mit knapp
mit personal unterwegs sind im gepäck
aber genau das gleiche
schnell schnell schnell man sieht mal
hier und mal da ein auge zu bei
sicherheitsvorschriften bei sonst
macht man dass wir hier so und wir
hatten wir als vorletztes wochenende
lufthansa-maschine diesen weg gegangen
man kann daran hätten wir damals war
aber dafür service ist auch kein
flugbetrieb
das ist keine abwertung was sind für
service beschreibt ein mann steckt
einmal drei stunden vorher da sein damit
man den koffer abgibt damit man durch
die sicherheitskontrolle kommt ohne
kommt mal drin anfangen würde man will
noch weiter nach los angeles überlegt ob
es nicht doch schwierig ausgespart wird
sein arbeitgeber die vizrt ag
widerspricht verspätung aufgrund von
personalengpässen seien selten und das
personal würde sich am
sicherheitsvorschriften und regeln
halten
das problem jedenfalls ist da und
flughafenbetreiber bundespolizei und
sicherheitsdienstleister geben sich
gegenseitig die schuld dafür
und das sind wiederum nur die probleme
am boden denn auch für die flugsicherung
gilt zu wenig personal für zu viele
flüge im deutschen luftraum fehlen nach
schätzungen etwa 250 bis 280 fluglotsen
wo ein luftraum von vier fluglotsen
kontrolliert wird sie jetzt vielleicht
nur zwei und zwei können nicht so viel
verkehr aber beiden wie viel das ganz
normal das ist wie ein flaschenhals es
bildet sich ein rückstau
weil der luftraum schlichtweg überfüllt
ist und dafür gibt es keine gute
schnelle lösung denn die ausbildung zur
lotsen oder zum lotsen dauert bis zu
fünf jahre
jahrelang wurde bei der ausbildung
gespart und jetzt rennt man den lücken
hinterher und bildet massiv aus es ist
einfach schwierig fünf jahre im voraus
zu sagen wie viel verkehr sein wird wir
haben dieses jahr fast 300.000 flüge
mehr als damals vor fünf jahren gedacht
das ist einer der wesentlichen gründe
warum wir zu wenig lotsen haben die
vorgaben kommen von der eu-kommission
planwirtschaftlich und im 5 jahres takt
das sei so nicht einhaltbar klagt die
dfs deshalb laufen aktuell mehrere
notlösungen die die lücken füllen sollen
menschen aus dem ausland werden
angeworben und die aktuellen lotsen
schieben sonderschichten für bis zu 220
euro die stunde
die menschen und das system sind am
limit der himmel über deutschland ist so
voll wie in kaum einem anderen
land bis zu 11.000 flugzeuge müssen hier
jeden tag kontrolliert werden
tendenz steigend die lotsen zu entlasten
werden seit 2008 10 sogar flugzeuge vom
stark frequentierten oberen luftraum in
den unteren verlagert das bedeutet aber
auch aufgrund des größeren
luftwiderstands verbrauchen die
maschinen dort mehr kerosin und
verursachen mehr emissionen das ist also
noch schlechter fürs klima es steht fest
dass sich etwas ändern muss und die
politik hat das problem auch erkannt sie
kennt den druck der klima proteste hat
aber mit rigorosen lösungen es kann
nicht in ordnung einzel wurde 90 nach
mallorca zu treten
aber wir müssen trotzdem nicht mit
verboten arbeiten und einschränkungen
sondern wir müssen schauen dass wir
qualitativ den flugverkehr so
positionieren dass wir die reisefreiheit
ist ein großes gut
eine lösung wäre weniger fliegt dafür
mehr bahn dass das besser fürs klima und
es entlastet die infrastruktur nur
aktuell sind die bahnverbindung nicht
optimal und das schienennetz ist
veraltet umsteigen ist also noch nicht
wirklich attraktiv um dann zumindest das
fliegen klimafreundlicher zu machen hat
sich jetzt auch eine bundesbehörde
geäußert das umweltbundesamt fordert
unter anderem klingt uns stärker
reguliert und teurer werden
dafür soll unter anderem kerosin
besteuert werden denn aktuell gibt es
keine kerosinsteuer und das verschafft
dem fliegen im vergleich zur wahl und
zur straße vorteile
außerdem fordert das umweltbundesamt
dass langstreckenflüge nicht mehr durch
steuernachlässe subventioniert werden
fest steht damit wir wirklich grüner
fliegen bräuchte es vor allem
synthetische kraftstoffe
daran wird geforscht doch bis sie
wirklich flächendeckend verfügbar sind
wird es noch dauern und bis dahin muss
sich jeder selbst überlegen ob er
wirklich fliegen will und muss und im
moment sieht nicht danach aus als würden
weniger menschen fliegen sondern eher
noch mehr
und das wird nicht mehr lange gut gehen
[Musik]
jeder spricht gerade über klimaschutz
und flugschau aber habt ihr euer
verhalten geändert oder fliegt ihr jetzt
weiter aber mit schlechtem gewissen das
würde mich mal interessieren schreibt
uns hier unten in die kommentare